hello everyone thank you for a well
welcome I'm Elena
I'm from ITV and welcome to my talk on
how to validate your clincher and model
very briefly about me I joined I teeny
last year and it's a TV that I actually
started building Kalenjin prediction
models for ITV hablas platform which is
an ad-free
video on-demand platform ITV has a data
science team or for data scientists I'm
an intern and were actually looking for
one more day science to join us so
here's a brief talk outline I'm going to
very quickly go through house above
analysis is useful in showing I'll give
an overview of couple of minor estimator
and they Cox proportional hazards model
and how to feed one to your data using
lifelines package and then we'll look at
the assumptions that disappeared model
makes and how to estimate the residuals
and actually estimate your model
accuracy okay so it's survival an
analysis was concerned so all
subscribers eventually churn but it
would be nice to know when they're going
to do that because if we know that we
could potentially postpone the time
they're going to churn which would be
great for the business so how to predict
the list the next of subscription time
we could use something like linear
regression but it doesn't guarantee that
the time will be always positive we
could use something like a nearest
neighbor or decision trees but it
doesn't give us any probabilistic term
structure for for for subscription
length survival analysis used in medical
statistics guarantees that T is always
positive and it also provides the term
structure for ten years this talk is
going to cover only the Cox proportional
regression model with known time varying
coefficients so how do you measure time
and when does the clock start so the
clock starts when the when the viewer in
this case the I TV have less subscriber
subscribes and it stops when they churn
we have viewers beaut of course
subscribers who are still with us we
also have subscribers who churn Andry
subscribe the green points they
correspond to the
essentially 10-year at censorship so if
the subscribers are still with us did as
these are censored points and the
distribution of tea at censorship isn't
seem to be independent from tea add
churn however it's not always the case
because actually schedule is actually
seasonal and these two may not
necessarily be independent so when I
started building the current prediction
models I had a lot of questions so for
example what they did to calibrate the
model on a Title II we have data viewing
data that corresponds to be yours while
they're subscribed as well as when they
are not subscribed can be used in the
SUBSCRIBE date or not what to do with
those who turn in resis cribe how can we
substantially combine their subscription
ten years data and what features can we
actually use in the model so at itv we
we essentially calibrate the model only
to the data that are retaining the
subscription we have a separate model
for those who turn and return we call it
unison returners and another model for
those who just experienced never churned
or actually already churned and the
features that we use in the model are
only those that describe the subscribers
but do not leak any information by the
ten years so for example but wouldn't
include something like total monthly
paid what what's the total their base of
of their subscription so this is going
to be the slide with most mathematics so
bear with me so T is a random variable
and it has a positive PDF f of T one
minus the cumulative f of T gives us the
survival probability function a hazard
function is an instantaneous failure
rate at time T given a life after City
it can be expressed as the derivative of
the log of the survival function and the
cumulative hazard function is
essentially a key motif of the hazard
and can be described simply expressed as
a negative log of the survival function
those are essential definitions in
almost all of the survival
so here's a graph for on the left of the
survival function feet at using couple
of miles Demeter and to the right we
have the key motive has a density
function
you see they essentially symmetric and
if we look at the rate of change of the
log of a servo that gives us the hazard
rate so what are we actually model and
how do we estimate the D PDF
well actually different models have an
analysis they attack all different
things for example kaplan-meier is the
purely nonparametric product limit
estimator for the survival function it
is defined as the product of the ratio
of number of observations a number of
events versus those that are at risk as
it's a conditional estimator because
every next probability of survival is
scaled by the previous probability
probability at the previous time so here
is an example i also demonstrate the
notebook of how to do that using laugh
lands package this is the date from a
Talco dataset the telco journey dataset
from cargo so at time 0 we have that no
observations so the observation column
is 0 and the survival probability is 1
for every one at time 1 we have 257
observations and the probability of
survival for everybody is essentially 1
minus the tooth 57 divided by the ratio
of what is at risk and at risk is always
adjusted for the sensor observation so
sensitive evasion is where they
disappear from your data but you
actually don't know their outcome or
they're still in the data and they just
reach that tenure so SFC is a product
limit data driven ratio is essentially
but if you had some additional
information about your subject such as
their age and gender it doesn't take
that into account so Cox proportional
hazards model is the semi-parametric
regression model for the hazard rate so
we're not morning survival probability
we're modeling the hazard rate let's say
we have some information vector of
covariance for X also known as explained
variable
we know their time to event we know what
is the outcome and then the hazard trade
according to what Cox proportional
hazards model is defined as the product
of the baseline function for for don t
scaled by the exponential form of the
linear regression so you can see that
only the baseline function actually has
the time as its functional input and the
exponential form actually doesn't be
reverse time the exponential form
guarantees that you always have a
positive hazard rate so see pH has
essentially two components the time
varying baseline hazard which is the
same fall subject but it varies with
time and time invariant partial hazards
that depend on subjects values for
covariance but there is no time
variability there so if they have always
turned and this model is not appropriate
they hasn't functions for any two
subjects they relate by a constant ratio
of their partial hazards so that means
that the that's essentially the reason
for the proportion and the words for CPH
you can fit your CPC pH to your data
using this Python packages lifelines is
a very well used very well known package
originally developed by Cameron Davidson
Pilon there is a psycho survivor package
was quite quite useful I've come across
six survival which is mostly used for
modeling hoax processes and I recently
discovered PI survival which implements
something quite interesting called
survival forests at the moment it
appears that PI server is not actively
maintained
laughs let's package has a really nice
support channel it also has very nice
website with tutorials so this is taken
directly from their website the snapshot
this is the derivation of the hazard
rate note that the covariance they are
standardized in the feet and the
regression coefficients they are found
using maximum partial partial likelihood
estimator and Newton Rapson intuitive
search method the ties in T in lifelines
at the moment our result using afferent
method so the partial has a fun
he's estimated first from the data and
then the baseline hazard function is
estimated from a human of partial hazard
estimates group by 10-year so now I'm
going to show you a demo how to fit the
kaplan-meier estimator for about
probability and CPH to your date so I'm
showing you which versions of lifelines
and scikit-learn am using here by the
way this notebook is on my github page
inspector so we're going to load all the
libraries that we will use and in this
case I'm just loading the data directly
from AI from a folder but you can
download it from kaga lab beginning
usually the link to the data set and the
first thing we're going to do is to
split the data in the training tests
before we do any transformations know
that in this case I am doing a
stratified and this is something that
caught me out before where I stratified
only on the target class sojourn without
providing it anywhere can give you funny
results so if you decide to stratify you
need to stratify on both I'm going to
use the socket survival one hold
encoding module to perform one whole
encoding because I want to reuse the
object later on the test dataset so
after performing all of this
transformation this is briefly to show
you what's the distribution of the
current class and the data so we have a
lot of churners at the start with very
small ten years and then a lot of
subscribers who are still in telco and
they're at much longer ten years and
it's essentially a like I you should
disturb you sure of of the class to fit
kaplan-meier today it is actually very
easy using lifelines you essentially
take up on my feet or object and then
you just provided ten year and turn to
ten year is the is a duration and
turnest one with zero and it
is it also allows you to see what's the
event table that it builds internally
and it fits the data very quickly it
allows you to see and plot the survival
function so there's something you've
seen already on the slides as well as
the cumulative hazard function so
because the data set actually
essentially terminates at about 72
months and the raw at that data point
the raw telco clients who haven't turned
it will predict a constant probability
of 59 percent after 72 months and then
we'll move on to feed Cox proportional
hazards regression so before I can do
that I actually have to remove quite a
lot of redundant fields from the data
that were produced by one hold encoder
and you can see here is that is the
yellow date put dots only correlation
plot collision matrix plot there's quite
a lot of highly correlated data in in
points in the data so we're going to
remove them and we will also remove the
total charges because total charges in
this dataset correlates highly with with
tenure and after we do that we can then
carry on and call the Cox pH filter in
this case I am using a small penalizes
it's hell LTO penalize er but it will
succeed even without it the output of C
pH you can see it using print summary
and it gives a really nice summary out
with every covariant with corresponding
coefficient the exponential of the
coefficient the p-value for the
coefficient and the lower and the upper
bounds it also gives you something like
a concurrent score and look likelihood
ratio I will talk about those a bit
later but because I've pretty much used
all of the features except once the
world redundant there is quite a lot of
features here and you can see a lot of
these features actually not
statistically significant so their
p-value is very large so let's go back
to the slides
oops sorry
okay so we have filled the model and now
the question is is it any good so let's
take a look at the assumptions that the
PTC pH model makes it's the regression
model and it is making at least the
following assumptions so if you don't
perform any transformations on your
Kabir eats there will be a linearity in
the curved areas as well as the
multiplicative covariant effect and the
hazard rate CPH the underlying
assumption is the proper proportionality
of the hazard function for any two
objects and there are ways to test
whether that holds or not of course we
assume that there are no outliers in the
data so no significant influential data
points and finally we also assume that
the model can correctly predict current
for different customer risk groups so
they did the model is correctly
calibrated so for each assumption we're
going to look at this method essentially
to check whether this assumption holds
for the first we'll look at martingale
residuals how to calculate the mean
interpret them something called
concordantly in concordance in
concordance index and the owner
concordance we'll look at rofl residuals
for the proportionality assumption
deviance and score residuals and the IEC
and the Briah score for survival
analysis so what is the concordance
score so we simply can concordant
instincts top in alignment if we take
any two subjects and compare their
hazard rate if the first subject hazard
rate is greater than the second subject
and its 10-year is less than the second
subject these pairs are concordant
similarly is the first subject hazard
rate is less than the second subject
slopes and sorry and his or her ten year
is greater than these pairs are also
concordant any other combination
essentially imply that the these two
pairs are not concurrent laugh lines
package provides a concordance index
calculation so in the absence of ties
every record will be compared to every
write other
record so there will be essentially a
binomial number coefficient of
comparisons tied observations they are
excluded from comparison
however the sensitive situations they
are included in the comparison and
because of that sense of observations
they may result in the upward bias in
the C score hajime ona and others from
the harvard university they proposed an
estimator which is meant to be free of
central distribution so it's definition
is essentially it's the concordance
index but it's weighted by the censoring
probability direct using the
kaplan-meier st near just like if you
have a distribution essentially a churn
distribution with churn ten years you
can create a censoring probability with
data points that are censored an IBC W
stands for inverse probability of
censoring weights
oona concordance index is actually
implemented inside its survival and
we'll look at how to use it so let's
move on to the residuals this is the
regression model and why to get
residuals in one we should look at and
it's essentially defined as the
difference between observed and expected
at time T the residuals are they have an
upper bound of one for uncensored
observations and an upper bound of 0 for
sensitive observations but they have no
lower lower bound so essentially they
are quite not not very symmetrical
positive martica residuals they
essentially implied that the hazard is
underestimated and negative red
residuals imply that the hazard is
overestimated or you are dealing with a
censored observation so here is the plot
of martingale residuals on ITV's owned
for a cylinder model this is it it is
essentially a plot of the residuals
versus duration so we can see there is
there are two clustering around the 12
and 24 months this corresponds to
clients who have insured and they've
been with us for this long this was
estimated at end of May
but overall you see some outliers or
data points that are essentially have
very large martingale residual
calculated for them but it's very
difficult to judge what is actually
going on and in order to spot
non-linearity we have to overlay what's
called the lowest lines or locally
scatter plot smoothing lines a lifelines
package allows you to calculate that and
so you can calculate an overlay to your
magic a residual plot here is a my
sinking residual plot so you don't you
don't have to plot them against
iteration you can also plot them against
the covariance that he used or even
don't use in your model here is an
example of a martingale residual plot
again something called sticky score this
is the feature that we calculated OECD
which is essentially a product of the US
run a diversity and they are monthly
loyalty so it's their stickiness how
often they come back to the hub or ha+
and it's always normalized by the period
that you calculated for so we're not
actually leaking the the length of the
chain either you're calculating form so
I didn't despondently non-linearity we
need to add the lowest lines which is
the scatter plot smoothing lines so here
we can see that there is non-linearity
in this in the data essentially that's
why using this Coverity is part of the
model and we make largest errors for the
smallest sticky score because martingale
residuals are not symmetric it's still
fairly difficult to judge what is going
on so deviance residuals they are a
transformation on martingale residuals
to achieve that symmetry they have the
same sign interpretation as martica
residuals and they can be used to
examine the functional model feet as
well as to identify the outliers in the
data so here's the plot of the same
feature sticky score now using the evens
residuals much easier to see what's
actually going on so we see we're making
largest
obtaining largest residuals for current
customers that actually exhibits its
highest
his core and it makes sense because we
expect high sticky score to actually
belong to loyal loyal subscribers and
the error in this case deviance
residuals smaller for four customers
who've been with us so who are still
with us shorten residual is used to test
proportionality hazardous
proportionality of the hazards
assumption is defined for each Cabiria
and it's the difference between the
observed and the average Coverity in the
risk set at each duration it's not
defined for censored observations here
is a graph of shown for residuals that
is available to calculate and plot using
LaFrance package lifelines actually
scales the shortfall residuals by
variance covariance matrix of the
coefficients so Laplace actually
provides you by default these lowest
lines and any departure from a constant
line means essentially you've got the
Assumption doesn't hold so how to fix it
small cut corn score implies low
accuracy and to fix that you would
introduce new features and the futures
would depend on whether you are over or
under estimating the hazards if you have
large martingale residuals with non
constant lowest lines then consider
introducing interactive terms or even
changing the form of the covariances for
example squaring or cubing them the
proportionality assumption if it doesn't
hold and stratify the covariance by the
Cabiria that breaks the assumption so
laugh lands librarian will allow you to
perform what's called a non-interactive
stratification meaning that the baseline
hazard function will vary by that
covariant there is also another method
which is called interaction model
certification meaning that the
regression coefficients will vary by the
Coverity by the covariance strata so now
we're going to look at the again
demonstration for how to calculate the
scores
so now you know Woody's concordance
index the summary from Latin Spanish
will output concurrence index for you
and obviously the higher the close to 1
the better also log likelihood ratio
test the higher this values the better
the more essentially impactful yoga
various are but because there are so
many covers there are no statistically
statistically significant I'm going to
remove them I'm going to just leave
seven and repeat the model using seven
covariance only so the upper of the
repeat is actually really obtained a
very close concordance course the
previous ones eighty six and still are a
bhoot likelihood ratio test by the way I
forgot to mention the interpretation of
the coefficient so negative coefficients
they have a reductive effect on your
hazard and positive coefficient have an
increasing effect on your hazard so for
example in this case anybody who have
multiple lines is less likely to churn
so their hazard rate is actually lower
than those who don't have multiple lines
okay and also I'm just showing
demonstrating here how to plot the
different survival graphs
so we're going to calculate the
concordance index it is so it's its
output of the print of the summary feed
from Lapland package and it's also
available through the cyclists survival
but you need to transform the data
before you can use it we recycle
survival to calculate owner UNIX
concordance index it is a call to a
concordance index I pcw function from
socket survival package and so here in
this case it's actually very close to
the just EC index it's 88 versus 86 okay
I'm just going to scroll through these
this section we'll come back to that and
we'll talk about the martingale
residuals how to do that it's actually
very easy to calculate martingale
residuals using la fans package it's
just the computer residuals on your
fitted function and you just specify the
type of residues you want so in this
case it's martingale and I'm using it
doesn't allow you to plot the results
that easily so you have to write your
own plotting essentially function but
lefland package does calculate does have
a way to calculate the lowest lines so
here we can see that for telco data set
we have quite a bit of non-linearity at
the start and towards the end and also
demonstrate very quickly how to
calculate the Devens residuals plotting
martica residuals against a binary
Cabiria doesn't provide that much inside
but for example here contract months two
months we see that largest residual is
where the quadric month two months is
yes and small as where it's not but this
could also be just purely a distribution
that comes from your data so davian's
residuals
it's exactly the same function call
where you just specify dillion's for the
type of residual and you plot it's much
easier to see what's going on
the highest at the start for churned and
then the error increases towards the
greater taneous for the ones who are
still subscribed okay in this notebook
I'm also providing you an example of how
to calculate the score residuals and
shown for residual there are two ways to
calculate is in using reference package
one is just by purely calling the
calculator compute residuals method and
another one is by calling something
called
check assumptions which is a really
useful function and it provides these
plots for every coverity in your model
so essentially you need to look at the
lowest lines and any departure from a
constant line means that the assumption
doesn't count and to stratify it's very
easy to just repeat the model with the
features that break the proportionality
assumption in this graph you will see
that after you stratify that the
concordance call will go down because
essentially taking away the richness of
your set of kuvira's from an exponential
form
I swear you put that
again it goes back to the start
okay so we'll let's also talk about the
IEC for survival analysis how its
defined and a few other methods so
essentially I see it's a measure of
models and Stevens versus specificity in
case of survival analysis is actually
defined as he call variant to the
outcome concordance courses defined in
terms of covariance sensitivity is
probability that M the size of your
Coverity is greater than some threshold
even then the event has occurred and
specificity is the probability that M
the size of poverty is below the
threshold given that the even hasn't yet
occurred second survival implements IEC
calculation is actually can be used to
test each individual Kabir's you are
thinking of introducing into the model
as well as the overall fitted model so
here's the graph of the IOR you see from
the telco data set we see that an
average heresy of around 92% looks just
really really good but here's a word of
warning on I you see using chiffon you
see for swellin analysis from Julia
Griffin Devi and this is taken from a
blog from Frank Harris web site called
statistical thinking essentially the
warning is that I see may not
necessarily be very good in judging how
well your model can perform and in in
the future so for the element that I'll
just talk about the Brier score which is
essentially a score to assess
probabilistic models it's defined as the
squared average difference between the
probability that you predict a time T
and whether the event took place so yes
or no 1 or 0
the smaller the score the better the
model is calibrated
however the output should really be
compared with the score obtained using a
normal dose on something like a
kaplan-meier you will find in the
literature that score of point 25 is a
is considered to be offensive either
fence-sitter
but really the output should be compared
to the null model so first course in the
icy test all of them can be performed on
something was called the out of
example as well as out of time sample
dataset so out of sample where you split
your data and train and test and out of
sample we actually create come up with a
threshold in time and say I'm going to
use this data before the time for
training and afterwards for testing and
I would encourage you to use both for
survival analysis so in conclusion
lifelines and seconds well they are both
excellent tools to assess she performs
well analysis and build clenching models
they come with very good validation
utilities survival model validation is
actually extensively covered in medical
statistic and by statistics papers and
research and it's gradually becoming
more accessible through python libraries
for data scientists it's important to
use more than one validation if you need
to actually go to the accuracy of your
model here are the references those who
are interested and thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah so it's it's a provides you with
the probabilistic tennis structure for
each Tanya what's the probability of
churning in the next month's what's the
probability of churning in two months
and so forth that will be the main
advantage
[Applause]